العرب لا تسود الاحمق
لا تجعله سيدا
الاحنف ابن قيس سيد بني تميم كان اذا غضبا
الاحنف غضب معه يقولون 100,000 سيف لا
يسالونه فيما غضب لذلك جزء من من من من من
الشخصيه المحدوده
كبر دماغك يا اخي عبر الامور وتكلمت عنه
كثيرا مرارا وتكرارا يا اخي في بعض الامور
والله لا تستحق منك هذه الغضب النظريه
وهذا الانفعاله وهذا التوتر وهذا نقول
تعطيل تعطيل الحياه واحيانا ايلام من
حولنا على امره كبر دماغك يا اخي كبر دماغ
كثير من حالات لا تستاهل لا تستحق وانا
اقول
طنش داعش
نفس الشيء خيارات الا انت تطنش لك لك
خالد محدودين نحن في الوقت وفي القدره وفي
وفي نقول والله ال- ال- عموما البشر
محدودين في عندهم عندهم طابع المحدوديه في
ذلك انت يعني
الامور كانك تطنش كانك لم تسمع وكانك لم
ترى في بعض الامور يا اخي